lorsqu'il est question d'égalité homme
femme on pense entre autres à la
question de l'équité salariale au canada
il ya un chiffre qui fait consensus
chaque fois qu un homme gagne un dollar
une femme touche en moyenne 87 sous mais
qu en est il pour ceux qui travaillent
dans la fonction publique canadienne
l'inégalité salariale au canada on en
parle depuis des décennies pour
s'assurer à nos employés alors avoir la
parité sur l'arrière voici la situation
actuelle dans la fonction publique
fédérale
premier constat les femmes sont
surreprésentées dans les emplois les
moins payant parmi tous les postes
qu'ils payent moins de 65 mille dollars
66 % sont occupés par des femmes
al'inverse dans les emplois qu'ils
payent plus que 95 mille dollars et des
seulement 43% sont comblés par des
femmes
bref dans la fonction publique fédérale
le fameux plafond de verre n'est pas
totalement brisé des nouvelles forces
l'ict et salariales c'est surtout à
travail égal salaire égal
selon l'institut de la statistique au
fédéral quand un fonctionnaire masculin
gang un dollar sa collègue et elles
gagnent environ 90 sous amphètes
l'inégalité salariale est plus important
pour fédéral que la fonction publique
québécoise par exemple quatre
fonctionnaires québécois dans le dollar
sa collègue elle gagne tout près de 98
dessous il faut dire qu'au québec il
existe depuis 1996 une loi qui garantit
l'équité salariale dans le secteur
public mais aussi dans les entreprises
de plus de 10 employés
mais malgré une loi au québec il y a
encore des inégalités selon l'étude de
l'institut de la statistique dans le
monde universitaire par exemple quand un
homme gang un dollar et de sa collègue
féminine elle touche à peine 77 m
[Musique]